[Musik]
strafmaßnahmen gegen belarus nach der
erzwungenen landung eines flugzeugs in
minsk beschließt die eu ein neues
sanktionspaket entscheidung in der afd
die partei wählt alice weidl und tino
keller mit großer mehrheit zum
spitzenduo für die bundestagswahl
hansi flick neuer bundestrainer der
ehemalige bayern-coach wird nachfolger
von joachim löw
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster guten abend willkommen bei
den 19 uhr nachrichten an diesem
dienstag nach pfingsten für den sport
ist norbert lehmann dabei ein
showprogramm dürfen ungewöhnlich schnell
und entschlossen reagiert die eu staaten
auf die erzwungene landung des
passagierflugzeugs in minsk gleich zu
beginn des brüsseler gipfels und
forderten den aus dem flugzeug
entführten regime gegner und
journalisten roman blogger savage samt
freundin sofort freizulassen
beschlossen hat die eu ein neues
sanktionspaket gegen belarus ein
zentraler punkt der flugverkehr airlines
aus belarus dürfen künftig den luftraum
und die flughäfen in der eu nicht mehr
nutzen
außerdem sollen europäische
fluggesellschaften den luftraum über
belarus meiden
aus brüssel berichtet gunnar krüger der
himmel ist frei über belarus europa in
aktion twitter dazu der us präsident
schaut man genau hin dann meiden nicht
alle den luftraum aber die reaktion der
eu in der flugzeug affäre macht eindruck
zumindest auf sie selbst
lukaschenko hat uns alle geeint mit
seiner idiotischen aktion
die eu wirft belarus nun ganz offiziell
entführung vor die einer europäischen
maschine die von roman botta savage und
seine freundin das haben wir ganz
entschieden verurteilt
und wir haben bereits aufgefordert die
beiden umgehend freizulassen
dazu haben sich die staats und
regierungschefs auf ein maßnahmenpaket
geeinigt darin die einschränkungen für
den flugverkehr
aber auch weitere kontensperrungen und
einreiseverbote gegen einzelpersonen und
erstmals sanktionen gegen die wirtschaft
das ist eine steigerung es geht nicht
nur um sanktionen gegen ein paar weitere
funktionieren sondern um sanktionen
gegen die wirtschaftsbereiche die dem
machtapparat am nächsten steht
doch alexander lukaschenko hang
politisch und wirtschaftlich nicht in
europa sondern
russland eine russlandpolitik aber fehlt
der eu
das sei ein längerer prozess denn das
ganze zu einer gemeinschaftlichen
einschätzung unserer russland politik
führt dann wäre ja schon sehr viel
gewonnen
so lässt dieser gipfel zwei lesarten zug
die eu entschlossen und zögerlich
zugleich der in brüssel ist anne
gellinek für uns alle was können die
brüsseler beschlüsse denn bewirken
eins muss man lukaschenko lassen er hat
es geschafft die eu wieder zusammen zu
schweißen und für europäische
verhältnisse in lichtgeschwindigkeit
haben sich die staats und
regierungschefs auf ein neues
sanktionspaket gegen belarus geeinigt
das signal sein wir 27 sprechen mit
einer stimme
und wir lassen uns eine solche
räuberpistole wie die in minsk nicht
bieten was die wirksamkeit der
sanktionen angeht so muss man der weit
halber sagen dass ein land wie belarus
das nicht stark wirtschaftlich mit der
eu verflochten ist natürlich auch nicht
so angreifbar ist für sanktionen die ju
kann hier höchstens nadelstiche setzen
zumal das system lukaschenko ja
weiterhin von putin aus russland
finanziert wird was die beziehungen zu
russland angeht so ist man hier nicht
viel weitergekommen hier gibt es sehr
viel weniger einigkeit als beim thema
bilder rust die staats und
regierungschefs haben das gestern abend
diskutiert und dann auf wiedervorlage
gelegt für den nächsten gipfel im juni
vielen dank an und nach brüssel der am
sonntag verhaftet
roman prokoph sitzt ganz offenbar in
minsk im gefängnis es gibt eine
videobotschaft viele vermuten seine
aussagen wurden erzwungen
nicht nur die eu auch die vereinten
nationen fördern der blogger müsse jetzt
sofort freigelassen werden
mehr dazu von für begangen
dass ihr sohn in gefahr ist wussten die
eltern von roman protosevich nun müssen
sie ihn in einem video sehen das den
oppositionellen journalisten in
gefangenschaft zeigt und indem er
ankündigt mit den ermittlern zu
kooperieren
das sind nicht seine worte und das ist
nicht seine art zu reden
es ist klar dass er den text abliest er
wird dazu gezwungen wo man kann auch gar
nicht gestehen was ihm vorgeworfen wird
weil er keine massenunruhen organisiert
hat während der landesweiten
demonstrationen für demokratie im
letzten jahr leitet romankiewicz nidda
ein internetportal das videos und
informationen über anstehende proteste
teilt damit gerät das netzwerk ins
visier von alexander lukaschenko
der verfolgt seine kritiker brutal eu
sanktionen werden ihnen davon nicht
abbringen sind sich viele polit experten
und oppositionelle heute einig das
problem ist ein terroristisches regime
das wahlen gefälscht hat regelmäßig die
verfassung und internationales recht
bricht in ihrem polnischen exil bangen
die eltern von romantischer savage um
das leben des 26 jährigen
ich bin mir fast sicher dass sie ihm
etwas antun werden wie sie es jetzt in
unseren körpern ständig tun und dann
sagen sie es sei ein herzinfarkt oder
ein selbstmord oder sonstwas gewesen
unterdessen gehen in belarus auch heute
die willkürlichen verhaftungen die
verurteilungen die verfolgung politisch
andersdenkender weiter dafür begann
moskau zeigt sich lukaschenko denn in
irgendeiner weise beeindruckt von den
maßnahmen nein bisher tut er das nicht
und es ist auch eher wahrscheinlich dass
er versuchen wird diese eu sanktionen
noch für seine eigenen zwecke zu nutzen
indem er zum beispiel seinem publikum
versucht macht weiszumachen dass der
westen feindselig gestimmt sei gegen
belarus eine sehr verlässliche
geldquelle für minsk das ist sanktionen
hin oder her moskau ohne präsident putin
wäre lukaschenko schon lange nicht mehr
an der macht und moskau tut das nicht
ohne eigennutz denn russland möchte
schon lange belarus in einem unionsstaat
drängen und je schwächer lukaschenko ist
je abhängiger er von putin wird
umso wahrscheinlicher wird dieses
szenario was bedeutet die festnahme
prozess für die opposition in belarus
dass lukaschenko brutal gegen
regime-gegner im eigenen land vorgeht
das war lange klar aber dass diese
menschen auch im europäischen ausland
nicht vor lukas schenk und dem
belarussischen kgb sicher sind dass es
eine neue stufe der bedrohung und
insofern haben die oppositionellen mit
denen wir in den letzten tagen kontakt
haben große sorge um das leben von roman
prokoph savage aber auch um ihre eigene
sicherheit
erschwerend kommt hinzu dass es jetzt
viel schwieriger wird belarus zu
verlassen für diejenigen die noch im
land sind wenn die eu keine
belarussischen flüge auf ihrem
territorium mehr zulässt vielen dank für
begann moskau nachdem sich der eu gipfel
ja gestern erstmal mit belarus
beschäftigen musste ging es heute um die
themen die man sich eigentlich
vorgenommen hatte eine kontroverse
diskussion gab es beim klimaschutz wie
bis 2030 55 prozent kohlendioxid
eingespart werden können will die eu
kommission nun bis mitte juli
ausarbeiten
sie prüft ein co2 preissystem für
gebäude und straßenverkehr
ähnlich dem emissionshandel für
kraftwerke und fabriken nach deutschland
da haben die afg mitglieder ihr
spitzenduo für die bundestagswahl
bestimmt und sich für alice weidl und
timo grub aller entschieden die vom
rechtsaußen lager der partei unterstützt
werden
das andere duo dass der gemäßigteren
seite um ko parteichef leuten zu
gerechnet wird scheiterte klar
aus berlin christian hübsche
es gewinnt das team das sich mit dem
radikalen teil der partei offen
arrangiert hat alice weidl aus dem
westen und tino keller aus dem osten
führen die afg in den
bundestagswahlkampf
das prominente duo gewinnt die
mitgliederbefragung mit 71 prozent ihrer
mitbewerber joanna krupa und joachim
wundrak die beide den gemäßigten
zugerechnet werden kommen auf 0 27
prozent
die neuen spitzenkandidaten aber wollen
von einer lager entscheidung nichts
hören
das ergebnis auch ein klares votum für
ein ende der innerparteilichen
richtungsdebatte deswegen ist es jetzt
auch zeit die reihen zu schließen dabei
hat nicht mal die hälfte aller fd
mitglieder überhaupt abgestimmt
bei einer online befragung fast 50
prozent zu erreichen ist extrem hoch und
dieses votum ist lager und strömungs
übergreifend ansonsten hätte man das gar
nicht erreichen können interessant der
ist wer heute nicht vor die kamera tritt
co-parteichef motten gratuliert nur
sparsam via social media er hatte grob
allah und weidl nicht unterstützt
plädiert seit monaten für eine
gemäßigtere gangart das von leuten
präferierte unterlegene team wundrak uhr
tag verspricht nun kooperation also ich
weiß nicht ob ich jetzt so
hundertprozentig morton lager bin ich
bin als person angetreten um eine
personelle alternative zu bieten und das
haben wir gemacht
ich würde das nicht als niederlage für
einen dritten empfinden ihr ziel stärker
werden als die spd ihr hauptgegner die
union so haben es die beiden
spitzenkandidaten der afg heute als ziel
formuliert richten wir jetzt den blick
auf die korona pandemie die zahl der
neuinfektionen in deutschland geht
weiter zurück allerdings hängt das zum
teil auch damit zusammen dass wegen der
feiertage weniger getestet wurde
das robert koch institut meldet 1911
neue fälle binnen 24 stunden das sind
fast 2300 weniger als vergangenen
dienstag 33 todesfälle kamen hinzu die
bundesweite sieben tage incidents liegt
bei 58,4
wie steht es um das impfen von kindern
gesundheitsminister sparen hatte ja in
aussicht gestellt dass bis ende august
alle schülerinnen und schüler ein
impfangebot erhalten
die ständige impfkommission hat aber
noch gar nicht entschieden ob sie eine
generelle impfung empfehlen wird
erst einmal müsse geklärt werden wie
dringend kinder zu ihrem schutz eine
impfung brauchen sagte der stiko chef
jedenfalls sein präsenzunterricht oder
der gemeinsame urlaub mit den eltern
kein ausreichender grund zur wirtschaft
das bruttoinlandsprodukt ist zu
jahresbeginn etwas stärker eingebrochen
als erwartet das statistische bundesamt
meldet einen rückgang um 1,8 prozent
gegenüber dem vorquartal
vor allem der private konsum ist wegen
corona stark zurückgegangen und wir
bleiben noch bei der wirtschaft und
schauen auf den deutschen wohnungsmarkt
hier bahnt sich eine grossfusion an die
beiden größten deutschen
immobilienkonzerne wo novia und deutsche
wohnen wollen sich zusammenschließen
konkret liegt den aktionären der
deutsche wohnen 1 18 milliarden euro
angebot auf dem tisch vor novia besitzt
in ganz deutschland rund 355.000
mietwohnungen deutsche wohnen etwa
155.000 besonders stark wäre der neue
großkonzern in berlin mit dort dann
zusammen gut 157 1000 wohnungen roman
leskovar eine aufgeheizte stimmung der
die zusammenschluss pläne fallen das am
wochenende proteste gegen steigende
mieten in berlin
gerade hier ist der druck groß
aktivisten fordern sogar die enteignung
großer immobilienfirmen die konzernchefs
dritten ängsten vor dem neuen
unternehmen entgegen
wir sind uns beide einig dass wir den
zustand der irgendwie herrscht in dieser
stadt
der ausdruck daran ist dass die bürger
dieser stadt offensichtlich nicht
zufrieden sind auch nicht zufrieden sind
mit unseren unternehmen das das deswegen
es notwendig ist hier noch mal ein sehr
klares signal zu setzen zu einem
neuanfang zu kommen
der neuanfang soll in berlin mit dem
verkauf von 20.000 wohnungen an
statt beginnen mietsteigerungen will man
bis 2026 stark begrenzen
13.000 wohnungen zu dem neubau für
berlins regierungschef die pläne auch
ergebnis gesellschaftlichen drucks wir
erwarten auch von den unternehmen eine
neue unternehmenskultur keine
konfrontation sondern eine kooperation
mit den städten mit den bürgermeistern
den kommunalen gesellschaften und ich
glaube diese botschaft ist angekommen
der mieterbund ist skeptisch bislang
gebe es nur pläne für berlin
zudem habe man immer wieder schlechte
erfahrungen mit den konzernen gemacht da
muss schon einen paradigmenwechsel
wirklich stattfinden wenn man nun auf
einmal einen ganz wunderbar mieter
freundliches unternehmen werden will
ich höre die ankündigung und hoffe dass
sie dann auch tatsächlich umgesetzt wird
und bitte nicht nur in berlin das bringt
nichts klappt die übernahme werden viele
mieter den neuen konzern an seinen
worten messen beim nahostkonflikt stand
der ehemalige us-präsident trump
demonstrativ an israels seite
mit spannung war also erwartet worden
welche signale von der regierung beiden
kommen würde
jetzt ist us-außenminister blinken in
die region gereist unter anderem traf er
sich mit israels ministerpräsident
netanjahu und mit palästinenserpräsident
abbas nach dem jüngsten gaza konflikt
versprach er hilfen beim wiederaufbau
der zerstörten häuser stellte aber auch
eine bedingung die terrororganisation
hamas dürfe nicht davon profitieren
ein jahr ist es heute her dass george
floyd bei einem brutalen polizeieinsatz
in minneapolis im us-bundesstaat
minnesota getötet wurde
minutenlang schrie er ich kann nicht
atmen festgehalten auf einem video die
trauer über freuds tod schlug an manchen
orten in krawalle und plünderungen um
die proteste richteten sich gegen
polizeigewalt und gegen die
unterdrückung schwarze black lifes meter
wurde weltweit zum symbol und thema im
us-wahlkampf benjamin daniel die
umarmung spendet trost aber courtney
schmerz wird immer bleiben
george clooneys freundin ist zum kapitän
in minneapolis gekommen sie will dafür
kämpfen dass das was ihrem freund
angetan wurde nie wieder passiert es ist
höchste zeit für einen wandel bisher
haben wir ihn allerdings noch nicht
gesehen nicht hier in minnesota und auch
nicht im rest des landes
heute vor einem jahr
polizist der xo impressed sein knie so
lange auf george hals bis er stirbt
dafür wird er unter anderem wegen mordes
zweiten grades ohne tötungsvorsatz
verurteilt durch george hotz tod ist die
black lips matter bewegung noch größer
geworden massenproteste breite
solidarität die forderungen werden immer
lauter und kommen auch in washington an
so haben die demokraten ein nach george
floyd benanntes gesetz auf den weg
gebracht
es soll unter anderem die bonität von
polizistinnen und polizisten
einschränken und würgegriff verbieten
eine bundesweite polizeireform also die
aber bisher am widerstand der
republikaner gescheitert
das macht viele menschen in minneapolis
wütend bei einem gedenkmarsch am
gerichtsgebäude ist daher immer wieder
scharfe kritik an politikern zu hören so
lange hätten sie weggeschaut
lara appelle an die politik die
demonstranten fordern dass ich jetzt
sofort etwas ändert und zwar im sinne
von gesetzesänderungen dass ich so etwas
wie vor einem jahr nicht ständig
wiederholen kann
die kleinsten die gekommen sind können
zwar noch nicht begreifen was die
bewegung bedeutet die wellen aber george
wright tod verursacht hat könnten auch
ihr leben nachhaltig verändern
wie hat der tod von george freut die usa
verändert der frage gehen wer in unserer
zdf heute at nach in einer story zum
durchklicken unter anderem schätzt darin
eine soziologin ein was sich für
schwarze in den usa seit dem verändert
hat ja und nun zum fußball norbert jetzt
ist entschieden haben sie flick wird
neuer bundestrainer der dfb bekommt
seinen wunschkandidaten und der
nachfolger von joachim löw zeigte sich
heute sehr glücklich darüber dass man
sich so schnell einig wurde
klick erhält ab juli einen
dreijahresvertrag bis nach der heim-em
2024 hansi flick also soll für frischen
wind sorgen personell und sportlich
erkennt den dfb bestens bis zum
wm-titelgewinn 2014 war der 56-jährige
acht jahre lang schon einmal als
co-trainer von löw bei der
nationalmannschaft tätig meine vorfreude
ist riesig denn ich sehe die klasse der
spieler gerade auch der jungen spieler
in deutschland so haben wir allen grund
die kommenden turniere zum beispiel die
heim-em 2024 mit optimismus anzugehen
sieben titel mit dem fc bayern in den
vergangenen eineinhalb jahren
hansi flick versteht es größten erfolg
mit großer empathie zu verbinden
ja es ist sehr gute entscheidungen für
den dfb nicht nur weil er den verband
kennt sondern weil er jetzt bei bayern
münchen auch nur beraten der arbeit
gemacht hat die erste aufgabe für den
angehenden teamchef die qualifikation
für die wm 2022 in katar die kommende em
kann hansi flick dagegen noch ganz
entspannt aus seinem urlaub verfolgen
deutsche überraschungs sieg zum auftakt
der schießsport em im kroatischen osijek
carina wimmer gewinnt gold mit der
luftpistole vor russland und frankreich
und hat damit auch das ticket für die
olympischen spiele in tokio gelöst ja
und ein historischer erfolg der
deutschen eishockey nationalmannschaft
gestern abend in lettland nach 25 jahren
wieder einen wm sieg gegen kanada
das dbb team gewann damit auch sein
drittes vorrundenspiel sich selbst aber
auch neutrale beobachter mehr und mehr
überzeugend waren sich das team von
bundestrainer uwe rahn den weg ins
minimalziel viertelfinale
ein doppelschlag mitte des ersten
drittels durch die beiden mannheimer
loibl und plachta konnte von den
kanadiern gestern in riga nicht mehr
gekontert werden
den einzigen gegentreffer sowie das
dritte deutsche tor durch holzer zum 3
1-endstand waren teil eines vorher so
nicht erwarteten rollen tauschen wir
müssen wieder mit unserer besten
leistungen unserer besten einstellung
heraus kommen und dann werden wir auch
da erfolgreich sein
loibl spielt auf die nächste
vorrundenbegegnungen morgen nachmittag
an in der sich überraschend starke
deutsche wird überraschend starken
kasachen messen werden
das kriegt ja viel versprechend das was
im sport im gegensatz zum wetter nämlich
vom wonnemonat mai kann dieses jahr
nicht die rede sein
es ist eher ein nasskalter dauer april
und so bleibt es auch morgan wann es
endlich wärmer wird das erfahren wir
gleich von esther lee das war es von uns
schön dass sie dabei war claus kleber
freut sich und drei viertel 10 auf sie
und wir sind morgen noch einmal da punkt
7 einen gemütlichen abend noch chips
[Musik]
ein schöner name und herzlich willkommen
zum wetter dauer aprilwetter im mai und
das setzt sich vor zumindest in den
nächsten tagen wir bekommen erneut kalte
luft aus dem nordwesten und in bendern
kommt hier der regen vorwärts im
südwesten da kommt kräftiger regen auf
und er dehnt sich dann im tagesverlauf
weiter aus die details in der nacht
kommen im nordwesten schauer und
gewitter auf ansonsten erreicht uns
dieses regengebiet von west näher und
das durchaus kräftig ganz im osten und
im süden ist es trocken bei temperaturen
im süden an den alpen um null grad und
10 grad im südwesten deutschlands sonst
liegen wir zwischen 3 und 9 grad
morgen also ein durchwachsener tag
erneut im norden schauer und gewitter im
süden da ist dieses regengebiet was sich
langsam nach süden verlagert oder an den
alpen da scheint am längsten die sonne
die temperaturen höchstwerte dort bis 18
grad ansonsten liegen wir zwischen 10
und 16 grad
die kommenden tage am donnerstag weitere
schauer und gewitter mit viel wind bei
12 bis 19 grad am freitag wird es
allmählich trockener und wärmer von
westen her mit sonnenschein und samstag
auch bis 21 grad damit ein schöner abend